share you brother I gotta set you free  okay you got seven minutes stay focused  the art in here is worth millions  proceed to step two  it won't open sorry man you're on your  own  foreign  [Music]  number three  number three come in  help me get me out of here  God  [Music]  got a Tonkin Square Park  do that for me  [Applause]  nobody here but us pigeons  [Music]  I feel you brother I understand  when I was a kid My teacher asked me  what I would say from my house if it  were on fire  they answered a Sketchbook my AC DC  albums and my ground chuck  I didn't mention my parents or my sister  does that make me a bad person  cats died  music face  but art  is for Keeps  [Music]